et lors d'une conférence de presse
conjointe avec le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky le secrétaire général
de l'onu a fait son mea culpa le conseil
de sécurité n'a pas réussi sa mission
quasi-impossible certes à savoir stopper
la guerre on va l'écouter
permettez-moi d'être très clair le
conseil de sécurité a échoué à mettre
tout en oeuvre pour empêcher et mettre
fin à cette guerre et cela est la source
de grande déception frustration et
colère mais les hommes et les femmes des
nations unies travaillent au quotidien
pour le peuple ukrainien aux côtés de
nombreuses et courageuse organisation
ukrainienne